I've just arrived in Ho Chi Minh it's
the foodie capital of the south and I'm
here to get my induction to this
country's incredible food I've never
been to Vietnam before and I can't wait
to get started
for me the idea of escape is to is to go
to a country where you're not noticed
bend down
more importantly turn the phone off and
just just disappear I mean really this
occur just me and food that says it's
10:00 in the morning and already it's a
boiling thirty five degrees
[Music]
that's just air conditioners not working
[Music]
this country is famed for exotic
delicacies and fantastically fresh
ingredients and I've heard the
Vietnamese are a nation of fearless
foodies their rumored to waste nothing
and eat everything everyone says in
France it's the nose to tail over here
completely different level if it moves
thetan that's new charity for me here we
go
my first stop is the mother all fresh
food markets Ben tang
visit Viet Nam's answer to our
supermarkets but here the food is as
fresh as it gets Wow
[Music]
amazing where's the fish section fish
I'll show you that thank you
it's the liveliest market I've been to
many ingredients still have a pulse
unbelievable everything's out open fresh
she's taken the heads of the shrimp
they're only just set vibrant alive
fresh and kick it incredible
[Music]
freshness is king in Vietnam and I'm
here to meet a woman whose reputation
relies on it
mrs. V Ching owns for the country's
hottest restaurants she creates a new
menu every day using the market for
inspiration so this your local market
yeah and how many times the days you
come here twice the average person in
Britain goes shopping once a week we
have to shop every day boy every day and
this is normal to have the folks out
here like that was a bad mix so if you
wanted to get wine they would cut it up
for you so they just do it yes it isn't
how we bite it just call them oh you're
not gonna waste anything I'm all they
down there catfish Carla you gotta buy
when everything feel like world.i strong
I would read them that small the catfish
bring they're tiny
now you eat the whole thing the whole
thing the whole thing you're not gonna
waste anything now we have nor dairy so
the bone is so important to get some
powder so no dairy and that's why um the
bone you're gonna eat everything you
actually shopping fresher than a lot of
Russians do back home
all this leaping and wriggling might
look the stuff of nightmares
but ingredients this fresh are a chef's
dream bees hijacked a stall to show me
how to turn these clams you just bought
into a stunning dish because I was like
trying to get into the Pentagon you
can't even pay open yeah so fish sauce
crucial again it's all charcoal is it
because you don't have ovens
everything's just sort of open flames
that's incredible look I quit that cook
love it can't turn the guests they're
done I love bees no fuss approach in
minutes she's turned raw ingredients
into the ultimate fast food they smell
fantastic food right I'm dying to eat
one of them I'm gonna pull out juice on
there then yeah
who needs a seafood bar we've got a
market like this oh my god
and I'm on here for a week so what a
great start
thank you so you don't think I've
learned enough in one week I think -
sure I'll come back at the end of the
week and prove to you okay all right
thank you they were delicious good to
see you love the Hat by the way vias up
the ante and now I have a lot to prove
he has every right to doubt me because
he's an insult to her culture to come
here and tell he'll be up to her speed
after 31 years cooking that style of
food within seven days